I mean,
I can guarantee that they will do their best to not give you peace.
As you can see, my eyes are swollen cause I've been crying this morning
because, um.
For the five years I've been divorced,
I've spent those five years still in the family court system,
still battling everything.
Um, he.
Anyway, um.
But that's not to say you get no peace.
I still have 100% peace when he's not in my life.
And I still don't have to touch his disgusting fucking body.
I don't have to see his disgusting fucking face.
Like, there's so many peaceful things in your life that.
That's why they try to throw the little bit of shit at you and like,
try to make your life shitty in other ways.
But the. It's only in that one little way.
Like right now you have no peace in your whole entire life,
because he is, you know,
woven into every bit in peace of your life.
But when you leave now,
he's minimized to just the tiny little part that he can fuck with you
and as. And then
you just have to make sure
that you take full control of everything else in your life.
Do you know what I mean? Like, sure, motherfucker,
drag me through family court.
That's the only little bit you're gonna get.
Cause I'm gonna make sure that every other moment of my life
is filled with so much peace and happiness.
I win! I fucking win.
It's my life. I decide what I do with it, when.
When I do those things and how I do it.
Do you know what I mean? So,
like, yes,
they are gonna try to do everything they can
to try to make you miserable
and not allow you that peace.
But you didn't leave for nothing.
Do you know what I mean? You'll find that peace.
You'll have that peace and you'll have that happiness.